[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
with no announced hardware additions to
the PlayStation lineup and the looming
release of Microsoft's project Scorpio
console it stands to reason that now
more than ever
Sony's e3 press conference will focus on
software first party exclusives third
party games and titles we may not have
seen much of since their last time in
the limelight perhaps chief among these
is the God of War reboot revealed at
last year's Sony presser considering we
saw gameplay all those months ago it
wouldn't surprise us to see more at e3
2017 we're also expecting to see
something about the Last of Us -
following its reveal at this year's
PlayStation experience it's unclear if
it'll be another teaser trailer or
actual gameplay but it seems highly
unlikely that Sony would avoid showing
the anticipated sequel in some way and
while we're on the topic of Naughty Dog
games uncharted the lost legacy releases
this August so it won't be surprised at
all to see Sony share more about this
standalone game next week I thought you
were professional oh you should relax
live longer insomniacs open world
spider-man is also likely to make an
appearance it's slated to release later
this year and with the same creative
director as a bombastic sunset overdrive
we're expecting to see some frenetic
gameplay on sony's stage then comes a
handful of titles we're not as clear on
Kojima's enigmatic death stranding Ben
Studios survival focus days gone the
platforming sequel Mac 2 and Gran
Turismo sport to name a few but although
they're not confirmed don't count them
out completely when Sony takes the stage
next week in Los Angeles keep in mind
this isn't everything that could show up
at the juggernauts press conference next
week for more on what we want to see at
this year's Sony pressor we asked a few
of our editors to outline their hopes
for ìiî 2017 announcements as a fan of
Sony I think that the most important
thing for me to see right now is to see
that Sony isn't becoming complacent they
had an amazing e3 with the e3 of dreams
as it's known with the Shenmue
announcement and the Final Fantasy 7
remake I think they need to dedicate
some of the press conference to showing
that those weren't just kind of like
flights of fancy and that those are
actually becoming substantial products
and that we can see so one thing is they
need to show off those games and we've
all seen the videos of people having
meltdowns the moment the 0.057 remake
was announced and so I can only imagine
what would happen if they actually
showed off a substantial amount of
combat and maybe go deeper into the game
and show of different areas that we
haven't seen before Sony's job is pretty
simple focus on the games which is what
they've been doing for the last couple
years especially if you look at their
pressors the press conferences the last
two years have been very gameplay heavy
with minimal setup from their presenters
it's been two years since Sony's e3 of
dreams when we had Shenmue 3 Final
Fantasy 7 remake and the Last Guardian
and I think for them to win e3 this year
they need to have another press
conference that was like that one that
was really like having these big names
like a game is so excited like all in
one place they also need to show their
continued commitment to VR because
they're a huge stake in that VR market
right now but I want to see more
meaningful VR experiences so obviously
have all the demos and things that
launched with PlayStation VR but they
aren't really
they're not meaty enough in my opinion I
mean Resident Evil 7 was a glimpse of
what we are is capable of in if in a
full-scale game I really want to see
Sony kind of push that even further it's
not going to be very hard for Sony to
win III if they just do a few important
things that is one focus on games that
are going to be on PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation 4 Pro and not really worry
so much about PlayStation VR they don't
really need to do a whole lot more than
show people that hey we've got more
great games coming for the system that
you already love the way something's
going to win this year it's gonna be all
about the games and I think the biggest
one that I'm excited for is finding out
what Sucker Punch has been working on
it's been three years since we've seen
anything from them and they've got to be
working on something that I just I just
can't wait for I loved infamous and I'm
hoping it's a new IP also maybe some
indie stuff I know they always do an
indie showcase so looking forward to
seeing what they're doing with indie
developers and stuff like that and we're
going to see stuff like I'm gonna put it
out there you got data of war that's
gonna be great
The Last of Us to probably some
uncharted stuff and then days gone as
well I want to dig in and see what
actually days gone is gonna be see a
little bit more of those hoards and see
how they all pan out to an actual game
so for me Sony always does a pretty good
job at every III I don't think they've
had many shows since like 2005 where
they've really stuffed it up but I think
what they can really do is continue to
deliver on those new IPs personally I'm
really excited to see more of Detroit
become human I'm a huge fan of Quantic
Dream and I think that's got a lot of
potential and one of the other things
I'd really like to see is single player
DLC for horizon zero dawn I feel like
it's really great timing it's not so
late that people have forgotten about
the game but not so early they haven't
finished it yet so I'd be really
surprised if Sony don't jump on that one
at this e3 when this year's e3 is easy
for Sony all they need to do designs God
of War for the end of the year last was
- for the end of the year and the nights
that night - has been cancelled so there
you have it what we expect to see and
what we want to see at Sony's e3 2017
press conference we're quickly
approaching the show and news will
undoubtedly release in the days leading
up to it for more on Sony's
announcements and all the stories
emerging from the conference's next week
be sure to visit our game spot now app
on iOS and Android we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
so the rabbits have been teleported into
the the Mushroom Kingdom
and it made the world completely
unstable and chaotic so Mario as a true
hero wants to save the day but this time
with some new friends
[Music]
and at first they don't really know each
others but in the end double form this
dream team that will potentially save
the Mushroom Kingdom
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and as the game is a turn-based tactical
adventure game combat is a really big
part of the concept so you'll fight wave
after wave and rabbit that somehow turn
bad and what we see here is just the
very beginning of the game so it'll be
perfect to talk about the combat basics
so the two flags you see on the screen
here is to tell you this is a
battlefield zone so you'll switch from
exploration mode to battle mode the blue
zone is your zone of movement so you
move anywhere you want in that zone but
you can also use battle feel ingredients
such as covers for protection so rabbit
Luigi here using half cover or full
cover and we also have what we call team
jump so by jumping or your teammates you
can expand your zone of movement so here
rabbit peach using Mario she's able to
flank the enemy so you can also attack
the enemy behind that cover and expose
them by destroying that cover which is
really interesting in terms of strategy
because for next turn you'll be open for
attacks and that's what not least
techniques
so from defensive ones like rabbit peach
shield boost or offensive ones like
Mario's heroes site he's able to attack
the enemy even if it's not its turn as
soon as the re moves
so this is a very core aspect of the
game itself so you mix and match attack
options movement abilities techniques
but we also have other ingredients such
as pipes rabbit pipes so it does give
you a a good move to flank the enemy so
here for example rabbit Luigi goes into
the pipe out of the pipe - the enemy
goes from Mario team jump land behind
the enemy in one single movement
sequence and then finish off the enemy
and what we see here is actually a
explosive cover so those have many type
of a super FX and this one was a push
effect so you can push heroes or enemies
out of the boundaries so again this is
just a glimpse into the basics of the
game and as you progress into the game
you have more tactic tools you'll be
able to do more combo setups you'll be
able to use different type of heroes
different type of weapons in order to
battle your way through the kingdom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Lasha
[Music]
all my Buddhism
[Applause]
Hey piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
in our new hotshot driver with a
promising career dominate Alfred racing
on his way to the top
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well there's a scheme coin there's a
wreck the charger throwing up our
champions weren't around it
[Music]
[Music]
coming out of nowhere to rise to the top
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the heart of the city street racers
prove their skills skidding on rooftops
burning asphalt and tuning their rides
[Music]
forge your own path off roll through
striking beauty of nature
tail and predictable ways on the open
ocean rapid waters or narrow rivers
fearless pirate rules guys spin between
buildings through the clouds
among stunning stunning perspectives
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we all started as one team we all wanted
to be superheroes for the same reason
[Music]
you're a traitor tweek and now you're
with a group of super traitors this was
started by you we are the ones who
walked out of the [ __ ] franchise
mysterion why would the Freedom House
out luck send a spy someone in our group
who pretends to want to switch sides and
join Freedom Pass
somebody who they don't know very well
well this bear is nothing more freedom
booty [ __ ] animal
you've got problems new kid whatever you
did last night got a lot of people's
attention bad people if you need
information just know you can rely on
call girl who does [ __ ] is that oh I
guess now any [ __ ] [ __ ] thinks
they can be a superhero
we're gonna rip you apart do mysterious
visit Union kids
hello toolshed toolshed is a catchy tier
class visionary architect and a
[ __ ] trader
[Music]
Eric you must listen to me get out of my
head Timmy your franchise is going
nowhere
face the truth Eric you guys are kind of
douchebags he just caught us douchebags
in my mind he did stop the fractured but
home who's it as a camera it's your
music player your flashlight calculator
and GPS navigation device but now
finally the most high tech company in
the world has unlocked the mobile phones
true potential so that it can do what it
was truly meant to do you're playing
cowboys and Indians
hey you kid we need you to come play
with us put on some cowboy [ __ ] and meet
us outside and bring your phone
we're playing cowboys and Indians Dickel
Inuits are technically Native American
you can put miss Schade
[Music]
these guys a new [ __ ] new kid there
was a sort of synergy of what we're
looking to do something interesting in
VR and we've got this division and
you're looking to sort of bring you know
what sense you have of storytelling with
him and put that into the context that
we are you can for the first time as a
player feel like you are in a movie
that's a really good word for it we want
you to take off the gear and still feel
unsettled
[Music]
what's working with Ubisoft we stumbled
across some fascinating research that
had begun in the late 90s essentially
neuro scientists had figured out a way
to upload brain data trauma emotional
emotions memories to the digital space
now we've gone and taken the next
logical step and we've recreated in
virtual reality
one such specimen so we'd like 22 coming
join us and experience the walther test
case for yourself that how do we don't
want to again
[Music]
[Music]
what you were experiencing is a recorded
consciousness it's not like watching a
movie so no matter how real it may seem
it can't hurt you
you were completely safe you were
completely safe
[Applause]
besides after seventy years the door
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I did not kiss the girls my lips are
moldy
[Music]
[Applause]
the Priscilla's shallows of Madagascar
located on the cusp of a bustling trade
route it is the perfect place for an
ambush
here is our gang of pirates the Raiders
going head to head with a gang of rival
players the cutthroats victory goes to
the team with the most loot at the end
of the hunt
knowing how to sail with the wind is a
pirate's most precious skill use the
winds to increase your speed or to
position yourself for tactical advantage
in battle to reap the most rewards
it is vest to split up some going inland
others keeping to the open sea
each warship has unique strengths the
frigates hull is reinforced its arsenal
equipped with numerous culverin cannons
the Brigantine is devastating up close
with a battering ram designed to break
any resistance the sloop-of-war kills
from afar with its crippling long-ranged
mortars and precise long nine cannons
[Music]
open fire
nothing was I do now
you soggy nothing
don't let bloodlust cloud your purpose
you're here for the loot and so are your
rivals store the goods then back to your
station the team that escapes with the
most loot claims victory searching for
more targets on the horizon our
sloop-of-war spots a rival pirate ship
further inland
with its heavily reinforced hull our
frigate swoops in to save the day
bearing the brunt of the damage
another day another victim
mr. Rossi vamos cantar Oh our gang of
pirates is now taking aim at the frigate
and it will take team coordination to
take her down
[Music]
yeah chillin
we can take a step with the enemy ships
broadside now vulnerable our frigate
rushes into border
the black and silver fish
[Applause]
pirate hunters have been sent in
signaling the end of the hunt they
target the Pirates with the most stolen
loot tomato captain or we are balloons
the pirate hunter defenses are so strong
that the only option is escaped the
Brigantine is sacrificing herself to buy
time for the frigate who carries the
most loot
the frigate now needs to make its escape
through the reefs
successful pirates know when to run with
their hulls full and the wind at their
backs atlas jewel of the Pleiades
[Music]
nova took us to the stars each new world
more incredible than the last
we had no idea what was waiting for us
the legion
which consumes everything in its path
they've never used StarLink before go
show them what it can do
let's do this my god
chase how's it going breaking atmosphere
even the odd
judge we need to buy time for me to jump
start the engine
they are resisting ice barrage linking
fire Mona
we're up against impossible odds but
together we will adapt
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not the most pretty I'll live
forever sing live with me with somebody
I just wanna dance with somebody
[Applause]
[Music]
one of us will survive
[Applause]
hey everyone I'm bebe Rexha and just
dance 2018 is out this October on all
consoles bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the child you would wait and watch for
fire
but you always knew that you'd be form
the word while they are
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we got Piggy's Sam looks like a war zone
which one
watertower got it
I'm in position
all the way dad will you walk in the
light of our father and be delivered
boom [ __ ]
[Music]
I love
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up guys welcome to games was
covered to e3 2017 we're getting ready
for the Sony press conference kicks off
in half an hour I'm loose James joined
by Peter Brown Mike Mahadi and Tomas Ain
guys we have seen EA Ubisoft the PC show
and Microsoft worked Evolver and a Volvo
although I over says de we've seen a lot
can Sony bring it to the table what what
did it who do you think that biggest
competitor is in terms of how good the
press conferences have been so far right
now I mean everyone's going to be
matching a lot to Microsoft obviously
Nintendo's tomorrow so the kind of alder
picture for now but I think of the press
conferences the strongest so far has
been new be soft right yeah they've got
the they had fun they had the most
surprising games
um I think Sony's got a hard it's a hard
act to follow and I'm not sure what they
have a con think of any surprises that
could they could pull out right now I
feel like they're gonna have they have a
lot of known quantities the God of War
the spider-man
you know horizon stuff that could come
out and Gran Turismo that kind of stuff
I hope they have surprises I'm not sure
we'll get back many of them I think
we'll get a lot of things that we were
used to seeing or things that are like
way off in the distance so when I'm
expecting like another III of Dreams
like 2015 that's gonna be tough I mean
they had a couple of good years actually
in a row where they announced things
that people were either hoping to hear
about or like totally surprised because
they just never saw it coming I think
kept doing that it'd be a little bit
shocking because a lot of the things
they've announced haven't really come
out yet yeah they're getting a bit of a
reputation for sort of announcing things
years in advance like Last Guardian
style or I mean telling me both of these
next ones are Square Enix for like Final
Fantasy 7 Kingdom Hearts 3 announced
them years in advance and just sort of
pissing people off mm-hmm do you agree
Mike yeah that what the Kingdom Hearts 3
trailer dropped yesterday during that
orchestral thing yeah next one at d23
the next one next year will drop to same
time I'm sure but yeah I'm kind of just
wondering whether we'll actually see
like the lat
of us gameplay at all or will see
Morgana for gameplay because they
debuted with gameplay they did but I've
been on neogaf not always the best
source but there is this one guy who
seems to be like mmm God of War might
not be very for showing this year they
might be going back to the drawing board
on it a little bit which is very
interesting I think yeah well I will
almost definitely see uncharted The Lost
Legacy yes
well really see in a month or two um and
then I think we talked about this kind
of like last week a little bit on a few
videos but I'm wondering if resin able
to remake would be one of the surprises
it wouldn't be a complete surprise but I
think that might be one of the ones
where you know riding the high of
resonable 7 it might be the time for
them to finally come out with it and
show us is it a faithful remake much
like remake itself was the first game or
is it completely rehaul I'm hoping it's
the former but I think now would be the
time to show it I mean with resin Evil 7
you have the evil within 2 is coming out
soon it's like survival horror is kind
of big again yeah and I'm that's what
I'm hoping to see and I actually would
not put it outside the realm of
possibility
I mean installed is important too and
they've seemed to have exhausted a lot
of the nostalgic opportunities so far
right yeah yeah there's evil to be a
good call yeah probably show not a hero
for resonable 7 out of me I got delayed
right yeah I think a lot a lot of their
games currently as the known quantities
like I think God of War will show up but
a lot of my Western games and I I feel
like I want a little more Japanese in in
there kind of like showcase and maybe
Resident Evil is a good way to that like
you said they're writing the high of 7
and you know they have a good
relationship with Capcom currently
between the Resident Evil the other
thing which they went all-in on you know
having partnerships with Street Fighter
and you know helping Marvel and that
kind of stuff so it could be it could be
I mean I you got a good shot of Resident
Evil 2 remake coming up I'd certainly
would like to see it I don't think it's
a as big a deal as you know it's not the
thing that's gonna win them a press
conference yeah us is something that we
really like yeah but I think don't don't
need a little more than that what if
it's from software
what if from software has something to
show oh man if from software show
anything labonte I will fall off this
case that's it you need help yeah if
it's from so [ __ ] all of you yeah I will
mean my coaches
to unquestionable things to each other
whirring and I heard we get it on camera
Oh Mel all right Sony's hearing me
please do not another word
now let me do know I would I think like
obviously we talked about this last week
they had a meeting between you know
Shuhei and is like a Miyazaki Sun and
you know the writer of the expanse
talking about him working with from
software recently so there's talk of
maybe a sci-fi thing and I don't know
it's a decent chance I want to believe
it's gonna happen if I'm being realistic
probably not I was gonna cos does that
not seem too soon after the race of Dark
Souls 3 like it feels like especially
because it seems like Miyazaki is just
going from bang bang bang
yeah and you've got to think like making
games like that they're intense long
process to develop them you would maybe
want to give himself a break he's
becoming a mercenary in the way that he
approaches projects right like he's also
the CEO of that company now that's the
thing to bear in mind bow how it works
now it seems like it's people start
making games and then he appear and then
he joins them and as his flaky years
yeah and steers it and for the bigger
projects for so for stuff like Dark
Souls 1 and blood-borne he was kind of
like their main dude and doctors too
considerably less so and Dark Souls 3
was kind of like him offering his
insight to it as well and also providing
some assistance to development and
design of it there was a lot more people
than just Miyazaki I know all the
publishers like Bandai Namco want to put
his name front and center as we've all
games it's not one map in a visually is
what yeah what team are doing everything
guys should we talking about ah the
known quantities that we know we're
gonna see so there should be some Call
of Duty World War two hopefully snack to
nacked
yeah you see it on my list knack to
reckoning they've actually so Sonya kind
of at the moment doing like teasing out
information on their pre stream so neck
two has a release date nice thank you
and a price yeah and it's not a full no
full price game huh seriously yeah it's
like thirty nine ninety nine dollars
yeah you can afford two copies man yeah
sweet birthday put neck in the bin then
leaving them yeah at September 29 is
knack a term for a bin no I just think
he belongs in the bin yeah but if it's
not very good
then we can use the phrase it's nakid
yeah Mary but but have a knack for it Oh
God
oh my god its neck again I don't uh so
we have that probably some crash
bandicoot crash bandicoot that's coming
out super soon right yeah it is
they are gonna be on the same trilogy
insane look see I love those crash games
but um I just want what there's one
crashing racing yeah I don't know how to
think about the remix cuz it kind of
looks like the movement on crashes looks
lower it could be I don't know cuz I've
been replaying them on I have them on my
playstation vita um you see it just
looks a bit oh yeah yeah
doesn't look like it has the the
purchase I guess the game of previous
crash games and we played it all in and
tried for over of course oh yeah and
that was kind of like a wake-up call
that was my momma all right oh I don't
remember this being this weird I'm gonna
climb up there and you were something
yeah I mean it looks nice I guess
the like weeds yes
yeah and so I don't know I think this is
one of those games where everyone goes
yes crashes back and the nearly saying
goes who cares yeah and then it will be
on discount on on PSN within weeks um
yeah this is a this crash is a low
priority and whoever's playing it was
replaying this is terror
oh it clearly said TNT on that box don't
spin I I think it's case wat producer
Nick margarita Oh RIA Mack mockery he
will be doesn't talking to you what did
you look good unless it snack um you you
mentioned
Japanese games not many being on the
radar do you think we'll see a ninokuni
- I reckon that's a there's a good shot
that way I don't believe it has a
release date yet does it think they just
sort of it they just did like earlier
today no okay there you go then so it
will show up maybe they will definitely
be there but it's on PC as well right
hey then yeah yeah but less than it was
showcased it was it was part of Sony's
yeah that was it's big rum reveal yeah
I'm like fine Cole ninokuni I like the
first one and I I think a lot of that
first game it got buy or not buy buy or
sold on the Ghibli
yeah aspect of it and Ghibli isn't
involved in this so I'm kind of little
hmm as far as I know they're not really
involved at all so I'm like kind of I'm
done with it now like I know they
established a world and that kind of
stuff but I kind of the charm was born a
bit thin for me on it and I didn't think
the gameplay was enough to certainly for
me to keep playing cuz it was so grindy
yeah it's very grinding I had a lot of
charm though and that's what kind of
like pushed me through a lot of it and
honestly the localization it was
incredible yeah I mean Welsh guy bang 3d
he'll come
but yeah I don't know if this was the
only representation of Japan I'll be
free at this point um I need a little
more I need some quirky Japanese games
I need something cool like I'm sure they
will yeah I need a hot action game for
Platinum Games yeah I mean though
unfortunately uh we also can expect
atomic days gone so we were a little
down on this last week we talked about
on the lobby cuz more zombies and
everyone's a little burnt out as we were
told
gods are responsibie no it's a harsh man
it seems like an open world zombie
survival game it seems like a narrative
state of decay without allies I guess
but also I guess I would actually play
this i canna came out on the tail end of
the zombie craze but I just reminds me
of Norman Reedus his character from The
Walking Dead but it looks cool like if
they actually I mean the selling point
when they first showed it was look how
many zombies we have on screen at once
or whatever they are the crawler things
but I like the idea of survival the fact
that you kind of put like some sort of
soup can on the gun to make it a
silencer uh I don't know if it's a soup
can be kinda yeah um so I don't really
know what to think of this game yet I
guess maybe this would be a good time to
show me more of it yeah it's like yeah
like we said last weekend what's the
hook again why is that I like it needs a
gameplay hook or something to kind of
distinguish it from this kind of plain
zombie survival game and where we've got
so many of them right now cuz this close
the show last year right yeah big reveal
at the end of the show
and I didn't understand it then and I
don't quite understand it now I'm
hope is that Sony come out and they show
us something really cool about the game
that all kind of gas amped up for it and
show why it it's worth paying attention
to but based on what we know now it
feels like a very plain zombie survival
game and ain't got time for that if it's
propped up against the Last of Us 2 that
would also be during this conference we
were saying like with state of decay and
play on owns battlegrounds they showed
two very slightly similar games in a
very close proximity on Microsoft stage
yesterday and I'm really hoping that's
not gonna be the case as you can see
that's not gonna be the case with this
hub noodle yeah Baxter's are Campbell's
but let's talk about the other zombie
esque game coming from Sony Last of Us
part 2 part 2 not Last of Us - you won't
last of us - no um do we think we're
gonna see gameplay yes yeah yes I think
yes I think it's about time I don't
think they can get away with another I
think they the first cinematic trailer
of it was perfect like they don't they
shouldn't be continuing to dig into
story too much right now I think then
you start showing off gameplay stuff and
how it looks and like I mean I want to
know who we're gonna be playing as right
yeah both Ellie and Joel were in that
initial this what this initial teaser
yeah but I want to know I think probably
the times right that Ellie takes over
yeah main protagonist certainly like
with the DLC it was definitely moving in
that direction yeah it would be it would
be cool to see at the show as well
because aside from like jak and daxter
games you have every other generation of
Naughty Dog you have the insane trilogy
growing up and then he'll Uncharted The
Lost Legacy releasing soon and then you
have the modern Naughty Dog doing Last
of Us stuff mmm last was part two would
be really cool to see I don't even like
with a game like this I wouldn't even be
surprised if they just showed more
cinematics I want to see gameplay but
yeah I remember I think it was the
second trailer they were showed for the
Last of Us is when uh Joel and Ellie
were in that car and he told her buckled
she fell when that guy was asking for
help when they were going in Pittsburgh
and that was awesome but I don't I think
they cut it off before it actually went
to the player and then not and then I do
remember they they did have one of the
press conference when that went into the
ambush right right in the garage yeah
but then they also had one where it was
the hotel you were going yeah so I don't
know I'd love to see gameplay I just
want to see more from what Naughty Dog
we don't know I think I think it will be
Ellie as well like showing her running
around shooting stuff yeah it's weird
I'm a bit apprehensive I was talking to
Oscar and saying we were both kind of
agreeing that now that this is a thing I
would I want to see it I want to play it
but I almost wish they hadn't done a
part - yeah but there was such a perfect
like the relationship between them was
so great in the first game you know it'd
be tough to go to the other side of it
and show it from her point of view
because so much of the first game was
actually about her yeah just the
father-daughter relationship they had or
the you know pseudo daughter but no I'm
here to see what they do with it I think
I think this might be one of those games
where there's way more to it than meets
the eye and there's something happening
between these two characters that were
just not aware of yet and it'll be like
a big twist um but yeah I don't know I
would have been happy if there wasn't
another one but now that there is one of
interest yes they had to have had I mean
obviously we all know it will be the big
you know we need a sequel this games
mega successful it's old Bank Bank so we
need another one yeah but they had to
have been confident in their vision to
kind of you know go along with that no
dog has some power as only they could
have put up for and stuff but factly
they've gone with it leads me to believe
that they're confident in something yeah
I'd love to see what that is yeah you
know obviously loads more of that and
the conference mm-uh we're also gonna be
expecting Detroit become human I guess
we will I mean did she make an
appearance I don't know if any of us are
excited for it oh I I really liked that
um when when they use her for the tech
demo okay I remember seeing that four
years ago and being like damn that's so
impressive it's really cool and then you
know you see movies like ex machina then
clearly just took a lot of inspiration
from that tech demo is it gonna be a
good that like I I don't
expanding that out into a full game and
I mean in in the Quantic Dream's style
yeah I'm gonna ask me nervous I'm Nev
never been a big fan of their games I
think every rain was overrated I think
I'm
of their writing is a bit hit-and-miss
so I think they have a lot of
interesting ideas that they don't quite
hit on like this
the thing that is attracting me to this
game is it's really weird it feels more
like a almost I want to say that as
suda51 style kind of weirdness to it
okay it's just
I will suit as soon as games like they
they aware of how camping yeah they are
this is a game that is stupid but looks
of it but isn't aware of it yeah kind of
like the idea that yeah it's the classic
David cage right David cage believes is
the grace right around and so he's
probably like doing weird stuff for this
game that's gonna be hilarious to us we
might in it with any luck or get over
Jason moments out of this game and it
will justify its existence for years to
come I never played beyond I actually
liked heavy rain but I never got the
chance to play beyond and I don't feel
like I'm missing anything no I'm curious
to see what happens with this I do you
think we'll definitely see it though
yeah isn't this coming out and fall is
it I thought it like I saw a listing or
there could be mistaken I mean we will
definitely see more on this game I'm
interested to see what it becomes and
yes guys got incredible arms room he's a
he's like a cyborg robot right yeah but
um this is Binary Domain uh too soon um
in terms of third-party battlefront to
do you think we're gonna see single play
ah that's a good question I mean we've
seen quite a bit already of that game
mmm I'm not sure if they going to spend
much time on it I think this my mean
they made such a big like Foss about you
know the John boyega tweet and and then
they had the big reveal with all the
influences playing the multiplayer so I
think I'd like to see more stuff where
I'm just yeah I guess I mean not sure I
do today as far as I do I have a
partnership with Sony for what's is
strong with Playstation yep so if they
you can't sell a partnership on
single-player content I think this will
be the more player moment whether like
you will get this DLC this DLC this DLC
yeah remember that during Microsoft's
would be weird to repeat that with Sonia
maybe they even said during the
Microsoft conference that battlefront 2
DLC will all be free and everything ok
that it yeah
yeah maybe I mean I think they'd agree a
moment ago off the uh sorry yeah yeah
yeah yeah that damn it it's okay
it sucks sorry I believe in you you'll
be alright Microsoft was uh anthem and
then gone yeah I think I think I think
this might be a good opportunity for
them to get a little more multiplayer
information out there for the people who
you know don't care about single-player
stuff and like I they want that
multiplayer game they want that might
play Star Wars game this could be a good
opportunity for them to be that cares
way looks like yeah yeah uh destiny to
as well yeah yeah a severe yep mmm-hmm
you haven't seen anywhere else yet and
they've everything DLC always comes out
first for definitely on PlayStation yes
interesting and I guess yeah ecology
World War two I'm yeah cuz if it's not a
Microsoft stage that's a big enough game
it's yeah I think it's gonna be very
shooter heavy this year yeah which is no
ideal for me like I like these games I
like destiny um and also I enjoy playing
quality but I think it's quite I find
them to quite boring to watching press
conferences I think other thing with
Call of Duty as well especially they
have all of their trailers seem to cover
so many tropes oh yeah there's always
like an exploding vehicle and you come
out of it and you're all groggy in there
yeah I like your commander who pulls you
up and there's a guy with a pistol you
know I mean and I just feel like I'd
like to see something yeah and it's
similar with destiny right like they had
the reveal a little while back and it
was it was cool and but it was a lot of
like improvements to the destiny we know
it was a very it was a reveal for
destiny fans exactly she's not obviously
not a bad thing because that's your
audience not a lot of people hey that's
plenty of people but I'd like to see
them sort of explain to me why I as a
very laughs destiny player need to jump
in yeah yeah see it was to me I was like
okay this looks cool this looks like a
bunch of improvements I want into
destiny but I don't think that's
terribly exciting to see a press
conference if they came out with like a
look this is a strike I'm gonna all
right cool this looks like a strike man
ah yeah
GranTurismo Sport uh has a release date
it's definitely coming up this year yeah
yeah um
okay yeah I mean I assume is gonna have
a big presence on them
we have some slow panning shots of the
car up close I really hope this car on
stage all right yeah please another
Porsche huh
Porsche is invested in the future of
eSports I don't know if you know that
let's talk a little bit about the so
there was a some rumors going around
today
Sony interactive and statement Europe
have been registering some trademarks so
detective gaff went full zoom and
enhance on it Shadow the Colossus well
by yeah is it gonna be another remaster
but then there's you know people being
like no no think bigger there's no way
there's gonna be anything sequel e2
Shadow of the Colossus I will eat my arm
if a Shadow of the Colossus to
appearance I kind of can't wait to said
yeah everyone make sure you get that I
would don't clip be willing to bet on a
yeah like a ps4 yeah a ps1 version of it
yeah sure thing is like you sort of
really see this more and more now is
that games that get a current gen
remaster because that's the easiest way
for them to make money on it right
because it's you don't have to rebuild
the whole game from scratch you just
upscale everything that's a very easy
way for publisher to make money which
can then be used to fund like sure Metro
right we've literally just seen it
that's what they did with the Metro
decay and it's a cheap easy win for Sony
right you take out this collection on
ps3 already I know I think so why don't
they dispersed yeah they'd have to
package it with The Last Guardian and
call it the way yeah something like that
like it would there would have to be
something more significant yeah but
these kind of remasters are really like
you the easy way for Sony to quickly
like rack up some points and people
don't really tend to think too much
about it like oh there's a Shadow of the
Colossus remaster oh they're really
releasing at the ps4 along with
Gran Turismo 3 and a bunch of other
games that people love from the past and
people like yep that's great sweet
moving on it kind of like deflects from
the rest of it with like a bit it might
be a bit thin elsewhere but I mean you
saw that in Microsoft press conference
right the one of the biggest cheers was
from OGX looks MacBooks yeah yeah right
right so maybe it's not quite backwards
compatible
but it's a move for them to say we can't
give you all ps3 games but here's a
bunch that you can play they would have
to reread sure the trademark if it's
coming to a new platform and I don't
imagine we're getting close to the start
of Sony's press covers now some quick
side questions VR I really hope they
don't play it yeah I don't want to like
we talked about this but it just depends
on like I hope it's not a big deal if it
is it's got to be an upcoming triple-a
game that's gotta be huge it's gotta be
huge if it's some stupid video shooter
again I don't care
no one cares stop trying to make it
happen do you guys like the the Star
Wars Battlefront like the x-wing mission
I was fine I like a full game of that no
absolutely not I also want to play a
Final Fantasy VIII or so oh you know I
never smile just I mean Farpoint was
fine I guess
well you know it's not about me more
than anything else yeah um Resident Evil
is still the best VR experience I've had
but I think I'm done I'm done with it I
don't really care about it much now I
think it's gone the way of the veto
session I think is yeah I think is
there's a lot of people that on one
surprising amount of people that own one
so that that fact is making me think
maybe Sony will feel obligated to make
them people feel good about their
purchase by giving them anything
something anything but as someone who
doesn't really care about VR it would
just I feel like I'll be padding and
wasting time yeah yeah leave VR alone
when the fun stops stop uh in terms of
hot other hardware do we think Sony's
gonna do you think that kind of bother
in the year that people say our
PlayStation Vita - what I would just
love the idea of a portable you know
PlayStation 4 it'll play please tune in
for games but like a lower-resolution
maybe with some anti-aliasing disabled
here and there it's not gonna happen no
I wish it would but it won't it would be
pretty cool though I remember the PS TV
oh of course
bring that back one thing we we didn't I
don't think you mentioned was the
insomniac spider-man oh god yeah which
I'm actually the more I think about it
the more I'm excited for it because the
creative director from
overdrive which like and then they
showed some few brief parts of it um I
really like a lot of things insomniac
does but I'm also excited to see if they
can transfer that like Tony Hawk Park or
movement of sunset overdrive I mean
obviously spider-man is like seems like
tailor-made for that another thing I
just kind of excited to see what they do
with that I'm assuming that'll show up
yeah yeah I'm excited about the nerdiest
stuff around it like who is that
spider-man mm-hmm yeah a Peter Parker is
there not like worried about like
fitting into the know I feel like I feel
like it could be a surprise for a lot of
people yeah like who is I'm really
interested in whether they want to
create a wall around it or if it's just
like I stand alone here's a game
spider-man game it's coming out in the
same year maybe as a spider-man movie
and let's try and do it right or if it's
the start of something because Marvel
seems to be getting quite serious with
games right like they're creating
partnerships in a way that they they're
trying to invest in games and that kind
of stuff and have high-quality superhero
games they've learned that putting the
effort in can pay off I've seen it
happen with Batman and so you know I
think it'll be interesting what they're
trying to do with that game the ambition
for it I think insomniac perfectly
capable of making a really good
spider-man game I'm looking forward
seeing that sunset overdrive was great
um yeah some more of that as long as
it's as good as spider-man to appear on
the PlayStation yeah they should
recreate that bit way you failed that
QuickTime event and he just goes falls
flat on his face in front of that woman
who's like oh I hope it's as good as
spider-man 3 the movie oh why why you
like this he's going for Russell yeah I
won't all rise to it nothing anybody
knows what that means watching just
trying to control you thank you
so overall I mean we've got like four
minutes until the press conference who
do you thinks gonna open uh Blue Point
Games with that rumored remaster of
Shenmue 1 - I think come on - laughs for
that jeez I think I know it was a joke
ok I think that's that is supposed to be
a thing that's happening yeah I'm
serious like I open with that
you never know then they go like at the
end and Shenmue 3 is still in production
yeah right we weren't lying about we
know yeah
screenshots yeah they'll probably start
with last of us to I think that really
the open instead of Enda I think so
Sony hasn't shied away from doing a huge
opener I guess so but then what ends it
and they need a big thing to end it
right knack to really I would say they
open with Uncharted yeah like I see just
cuz it's it's close yeah no actually
does that mean it seems like it you'll
see I changed my entering yeah back to
neck - oh uh yeah I could see them
opening with uh a chart at the Lost
Legacy we haven't seen much of Marvel
vs. Capcom infinite yeah it could hope
it could be here which excites precisely
one person maybe people outside right I
played as opposed to on the side yeah
but we've seen it we've not seen any
other press conferences and Sony has is
invested in Capcom's fighting world yeah
they have that partnership so that could
pop up soon in this I expect it to pop
up but I don't know that character
roster leaked so unless they come out
and said say like actually we do have
x-men and that character roster was
wrong people are just gonna be like cool
looks like more Marvel I'm happy with
that but um I feel like a lot of people
won't be um so except for more vs.
Capcom mm-hmm what are you excited for
Mike I'm not born three blood-bought
absolutely love they did a blood-borne -
I don't think it'll happen but that
would be unreal
I'm excited for the Last of Us but I'm
also excited for resonable to remake if
they actually show that yeah Pete I'm
excited for the unknown honestly I just
want ya this was Tony does best and I
can't so so I want the unknown the
infinite frontier if you think we'll see
any more no man sky is that okay no they
they've been doing that uh like side
note they sent out like 16 of those
they're doing some sort of arg thing
people like they're big like streamers
they sent 16 packages out to them with
codes and stuff yeah that's I don't know
people think it's like they're like oh
maybe we go here we can meet up so now
we've seen that's not true and I could
appear like as a his latest update to no
man's sky it's good enough man I got a
company we haven't talked about death
stranding but
we know it's not it's no I hey yeah yeah
but what is this bridges thing like that
stupid thing he doesn't stuff like that
no he's got something for nothing
that's what we know yeah that's true and
he is a he's known to cause some he's
known for some high-level Russell's this
guy remember we never forget Joaquim
Ogron wait about what haha that was
intense
I changed my mind I think the openings
gonna be metal gear survive oh my god I
forgot about like yeah mess and then and
then it leads straight into days
branding day from black and then it's
the awkward moment where kojima standing
next to another konami employee like
yeah mmm
don't screw this up buddy yeah good luck
yeah bye this good chance that that's
Ronnie could show up he's a notorious
liar hey buddy
what if there's another deshelle
Intelsat connects us it connects to
death stranding they are two entirely
different he's talking like a pokemon
yellow pokemon green fat no I mean he's
talked about you know the ways that you
interact in video games it's like but
stick with a gun like okay how they can
connect what if it's two separate games
it's somehow interconnected something
that could be interesting yeah like some
sort of companion game yeah I mean he's
here to show something presumably all
right I'm gonna have to cut off here
because we're getting ready to go live
to the Sony press conference make sure
you stick around because we are going to
be breaking down all the freshest and
hottest takes from the press conference
we'll see you back here the old rules of
TV are no longer with us we're watching
here and here and here
this is light to eat and we can store
more shows and you could ever watch we
can even watch on five devices all of us
rules of TV have changed time to change
our you get it
[Music]
that fastball first offering on its way
PlayStation days of play with the
limited edition gold ps4 at 2:49
discounted games and more it's nine days
of epic dudes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
let's do this yeah put some of this
[Music]
that's Manny's Blakey
yeah this way
yes
why do you always go where you ever he's
not being that loud
[Applause]
easy phones
there is
I still alive
the hell away
come & get it
[Applause]
[Applause]
drop it now or I'll kill him do it
I'm not here for him here for you Wow hi
Manny
hey yeah hey do I come on I wasn't gonna
let him kill you is that who the hell's
around here knows how to reveal the
carburetor just back up nice and slow
don't make it
please welcome to the stage Shawn Layden
[Music]
welcome welcome good evening and welcome
ladies and gentlemen fans and friends
this is the this is your 2017
Playstation showcase thank you for
coming like Naughty Dog gorilla been out
of control I thought this opening was
completely insane and because I had to
walk under zombies to get on the stage
just now they'd even tell me about that
last night we're glad they were here
we'd lie to be here we have a full show
ahead of us so let's just agree that we
love games and we want to see more of
them tonight that's all about the games
every year we continue to push the
envelope of storytelling imagination and
technology and 2016 was no exception
virtual reality is now a real consumer
product and our consoles are more
powerful than ever
offering 4k and HDR options would we'll
take it home for that with the launches
of PlayStation VR and ps4 Pro
PlayStation once again stood at the
forefront of bringing these technologies
to the world of interactive
entertainment and now in 2017 it
continues to be all about the games in
the past few months alone have given us
some of the most creative high-quality
and engaging video games ever seen
horizon zero dawn neo
Resident Evil 7 MLB The Show persona 5
and yet we have an even broader more
diverse selection of blockbuster games
coming soon you goofed that's the plan
right you will see tonight that
worldwide studios is bringing you the
exclusives you want and through our
strategic partnerships with third-party
partners PlayStation is home to all the
biggest and best franchises in the world
it has never been a better time to be a
gamer thank you all all our fans all of
you for your support and for making
PlayStation one of the most loved brands
in the world and thank you all for being
here tonight as you open e3 and
celebrate the world of games this week
is our web portal we have a web portal
this week live playstation comm will
serve as the home for hours of
programming including developer
walkthroughs Q&A sessions in-depth
conversations and so much more but
tonight let's recognize the art of
gameplay with a showcase of the most
anticipated titles here at e3 so without
further ado let's get back to the games
[Applause]
before I step off it's my personal
pleasure and a privilege to share with
you now a title that has a rabid cult
following around the world and has a
very special place in my heart please
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
all biological life must be exterminated
doctor get us out of here
Ultron Sigma has two of the infinite six
Gamora
we have panels we raised you as a zone
have you come to beg for life you have
no choice help us release
and I will give you what you give us
cause to trust you help us to find the
Infinity stones stone how lies at the
heart of know their witness to the death
of your world zero
his core routines have been rewritten by
the Grandmaster Nova major get to the
core
the time stone has concealed itself
beyond bell conga needs it
we had a tree our two disease reality
erupted Gabor was single
when you not bow before your God you are
those
you'll have your diversion make it count
no wait ninjas Dante can the ladies come
out to play
pretty good evany ivory care today
and I thought I'd seen everything we're
in a whole new world now we're gonna
find out what you really made up
[Music]
and know
in his land
[Music]
tell me so what's your native soldier
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
roll to take I'd like to try it again
[Music]
yeah
god
try to visualize the hostage
you understand I want
you're welcome to join me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
I'm not kidding anything I can't hear us
we're on our own hotels move you on your
position what's your flanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
are you gonna do it
[Music]
you said I was cursed you think I'm weak
because I'm not like you you do not know
everything boy no but at least I know
the truth now the truth
a long way from home aren't you
and here I thought your kind was
supposed to be so enlightened so much
better than us the gods of these realms
don't take kindly to outsiders trust me
when they find you and they
they'll make things difficult wait here
I will handle this
Oh
wow that was something that Dow fight
on our journey we will be attacked by
all manner of creature
to be effective in combat a warrior must
not feel for his enemy before close your
heart to the desperation close your
heart to their suffering the road ahead
is long and unforgiving no place for a
boy you must be a warrior but not
everyone is bad mother always said to be
open to those who can help
oh you were before doesn't matter
this boy is not your past he is your son
and he needs his father
what is this
it's the world serpent
what does it say
Oh sir
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh just a little longer
[Music]
hold on just a little while
[Music]
this is a night our people will remember
there are five cyber life stores across
the Troy we're gonna attack those stores
and set our people free
[Music]
that's what we are to them just a
merchandise on display in a shop window
let's get him out we'll stick to the
plan neutralize the alarm systems and
security
is ten minutes until all our teams
attack you're awake now
we gotta go what we can't just leave our
people behind it's too late oh say your
way to get shot
North our people need us alive there's
nothing else we can do
take up
we are superior to them that they are
our masters that's about to change
my name is Marcus and just like you I
was
but then I chose to open my eyes to take
back my freedom and decide who I wanted
to be now I have come to tell you that
you can be your own masters we're with
you
I'll follow you Marcus
[Music]
then follow me
we interrupt this broadcast with
breaking news police report that pro
Android graffiti was found in the
neighborhoods of cyber Life stores given
the facts is pretty clear this attack so
that's
away from the strap in town
different locations were hit and what
seems to be a coordinated attack this is
an alarming
numerous storefronts have
is done set a line
to ensure you're getting reports that
hundreds of Androids
Comfort II was damaged and fires
continued to rage in several major
districts
some people are asking have android's
become a threat to our security
they're coming
north
North right slaughtered the animals
my name is Marcus I am one of them this
is our story
[Applause]
discipline coming behind walls
across the galaxy to prove my
allow me to reacquaint you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome back to the stage Shawn
Layden
[Music]
okay buddy just breathe yes that was
quite the roller coaster ride for the
last 60 minutes thank you all so much
for being here tonight the future is
here and it is now with PlayStation 4
pro and psvr
we could not be more excited than to
kickoff III 2017 celebrating the content
and the creators who make PlayStation
the best place to play for gamers now
let me leave you with a true PlayStation
exclusive a true exclusive from
Playstation from one of the industry's
most respected developers let me thank
you again for coming tonight I shut up
to my courageous friend Romeo Mehta for
struggling on through and now everyone
please enjoy the ride
all units all units 1010 acid 36 in park
repeat all units be advised
shots fired infinite showers
[Music]
[Music]
Yuriy I'm here what do you see
find the rest boss wasn't dead looks
like the demons are moving in on Fisk's
territory you got it
I got this this minute fled through the
building eliminate them shoulda worn a
helmet
you got what you came for
you don't need to jealous too this
territory is ours now not today
Spearman the bosses here
hey Willie
nice jumpsuit slimming
wait the demons who's their leader keep
my metal Ivan maybe I'll tell
saving bad guys from other bad guys not
how I thought today would go
Hey
good
Higgs field that's actually really cool
Fiske your men are safe your turn who
runs the demons you're about to find out
check the roof here
come on
let's go let's go
did that just happen yeah
it's complicated
turns out Martin Lee is running the
demons like I said complicated sit tight
Yuri I got this
that helicopter is destroying the city I
know you need to break it down I know
maybe you could overhear Oh a little
faster working on a URI
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
hi is this the flight to Newark
[Music]
why are you doing this because no one
else will
this is crazy this isn't you
[Music]
you play when real fast
you got this you got this you got this
please don't screw this up
[Music]
mr. Lee
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's supposed to happen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
when all the stars fell oh hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so come on G let's go miles
welcome back to the game so stage here
at e3 2017 we just seen the Sony's press
conference everyone what are your
thoughts I knew getting you those
whiteboards would be a mistake that says
dry all right
that was dry yeah wow that was um very
expected and the things that were
unexpected weren't that impressive yeah
I'm actually quite taken back as to how
cold it was think dry is the word I mean
I mean I bet no it felt like quite cold
in him person yeah it was like yeah it
wasn't they they acted like they were
the sony of last year and the year
before we love games we've got so many
games and then it was like it felt like
they just just shout out a bunch of
trailers for games that are out there
already is like hey go kind of like the
composure as well yeah I miss unki jag
everyone missed his job I think it was
they had an unfortunate beginning with
the sound issues like there was no sound
up until days gone I think yeah then
Sean seemed to have a bit of yeah couple
as well like at one point of his own my
guys it's stumbling over his words ah it
was altogether it wasn't the slick kind
of focused like Sony that has a vision
and a kind of ethos that they want to
deliver through their press conference
it was very much a Sony that feels I
don't know like I'm kind of ambivalent
and almost maybe resting on his laurels
like it's in the lead right now it's
kind of compared to Microsoft and
Microsoft didn't have first party games
to show off even still I'm more
optimistic and positive about what
Microsoft showed off then what Sony did
and Sony had almost entirely first party
games yeah yeah and like man that is
that is saying something like that was
dry unless it was a Sony that's
purposefully pulling back for
PlayStation yeah they have yeah they
have their own convention they have
PlayStation experience where they could
announce big things and maybe that is
the case but it seems like a wasted
opportunity if that is the case like
you've got a lot of people watching you
might be done with it but the world
isn't quite done with e3 year so you
should still be putting your best foot
for
when you can and I don't think that was
impressive
I thought it was okay yeah yeah the
three like first party titles I really
wanted to see last of us to wasn't even
there
God of War I don't know if it was just
the sound issues from the stream but it
felt kind of messy from what I was
seeing at the cat I like the direction
they were taking but again it felt kind
of unpolished at this point they said
early 2018 so it's still a ways out but
and then days gone didn't really show me
much at all these stealth aspects of
sneaking through that bandit camp kind
of was just the last of us yeah um even
had Joel's like hearing thing right like
a low-key detective mode
yeah um and well I mean like the end it
was Spider Man which is also first party
but uh
mm thought on that game but uh but yeah
and I mean the ones that I was actually
hoping to see that we weren't like
positive would be there I was kind of
disappointed with those as well yeah uh
so kick it did kick off with uncho at
the Las Vegas II see yeah yeah I mean we
couldn't hear it yeah uh yeah
fortunately look great oh great looks
good yeah I mean I'm still excited to
play that oh yeah for sure that's I'm
already sold on that that's what again
like month and a half out um I'm like
you said they last year what if they
start off with last year they kind of
came out swinging oh I forget now with a
but they've like I thought I thought it
might have been wasn't it untied I'll
see you again it might have been anybody
I think was more impactful cuz we didn't
know what a lot of Tomb Raider
um but yeah Uncharted Lost Legacy I
guess not too surprised there yeah um
she have a colossus like you mentioned
before mhm that was on sleep like one of
my favorite things of the show oh yeah
yeah I'm alive that like but that game
originally came out how many years ago
doesn't make it any less impressive like
completely remade it that's yeah that's
definite thats not like a port that's
not a remaster yeah it looks like it's
built from the ground up yeah yeah I
said out eat my arm if there was a
shadow of the colossus to right you get
like one I got one tweet the guy was
like best dog Ian I'm surprised that
Blue Point is involved cuz yeah I mean
it's not really good stuff yeah they
they are that they totally the studio
right they totally have but this looks
like more than a remaster right and
which is why I'm a little why I'm a
little shocked cuz
they did what um the metal gear
collection uh-huh I did titanfall on
xbox360 which was that game ran a
awesome on that all there's another
recent remaster and it's it escapes me
was it oh did they know they were having
a rush grubby days maybe I can't
remember but yeah this looks awesome
and also just like the idea of the fact
that it's actually redone the controls
going back to the ps3 version or not
well I mean obviously if you want go
back to the ps2 but even on the ps3
remaster the controls are kind of neat I
wonder if they updated it a little bit
yeah the camera could do it a little bit
work as well would be untried there
Nathan Drake collection that's what I
was saying yeah I wonder if they if they
did any extra work because there's
always been that chat of that that cut
content or that oh that's right and that
was left unused maybe this is the
opportunity to kind of reinstate that
and finish what you know Team Ico
started that would be great I would
imagine there would have been like a
subtitle with it yeah if it was a good
version of the game but yeah but that's
that'd be cool that'll be real cool
unless they want to leave everyone sort
of in suspense before they talk about it
but more maybe could happen yeah uh we
were had horizon zero dawn the frozen
again another game that we couldn't hear
but we could see yeah yeah Chile yeah it
looked like it was focusing on the Banu
tribe which is yeah is that right the
the guys that were living in harmony
with the machines in the mountain was
that them I think I think that's right
uh there was a try but then there was a
side quest we could deactivate that yeah
so I think this is a round focused on
them and maybe wore off there was
something like that hey that's what I
seem like I couldn't hear much and
people were kind of moving around in
front me so yeah I didn't see everything
but I think that's what it's gonna be
I'm interested in that tribe was cool I
mean horizon zero dawn general right
yeah yeah a most great game I'm happy to
play more of it yeah um I didn't play
enough of it to be excited for DLC yet
yeah like ten hours of the game total
mmm it was a difficult game to balance
with Zelda which came out sick yeah yeah
but I mean people who like you who did
play a lot of horizon I'm sure that's
nothing but good news yeah yeah uh then
I mean I've can talk more about days
gone again it's still in that weird
place where it's like it looks too much
like everything else again I don't think
like my
has changed since pre this conference
they've still shown nothing that is
unique to it and unique cool you've got
a whole buttload of zombies but like
right okay what am I supposed to do with
them you want to shoot them like how can
I like it shows you manipulating them
somewhat to try and like over over run a
camp or something like that but man is
dry they seem to be flirting with a
narrative but they're certainly not
going deep enough to sell me on that
aspect of the game
yeah aspect that I was most excited to
see was kind of this right here moving
through the overworld and how the open
world aspect would work because that's
like I kind of a overrun Pacific
Northwest's you're on a motorcycle
trying to do that seems appealing but
what they showed was just honestly like
I said it remind me of joel sneaking
through a bandit camp and yeah are you
ready for doing things on your white
board
I'm not overall um I mean it still looks
really good yeah it does look great but
yeah coming away didn't excite me a ton
and I just yeah it's just something
there's something so plain about it that
I just can't get over the character does
really help yeah it's like he's crashed
down from Boss Hogg lights come on talk
about no I'm not into it at all sorry uh
well we did get Sony did get a big get
monster hunter world yes which I was I
did not see that coming that is a big
that PlayStation hasn't had monster
hunter in so long yeah yeah an addition
to yes started on PlayStation it came
damn a demo i got a demo of it with
Devil May Cry I think it was like that
and man it has come a long way since
that first game it's a much better
series now and you know it's got a huge
fan base and I'm excited to see that a
proper triple-a Monster Hunter game is
on the way to PlayStation 4 I mean I'm
so used to playing on a tiny screen and
I've always wanted to have like that
high quality triple-a experience with
this series and it's finally it's
finally then it looks like there's going
to be like no it's going to be plugged
into the PlayStation Network and finally
play with friends and
not have it be a giant pain in the ass
to make it happen some Nintendo stuff
right um but yeah it's dinosaurs are
stupid yeah I was the next one he's
there like ghillie suit on all son
hasn't seen you have a specific show to
explore dinosaur games oh I don't know
Wow somewhere we all look alike to you
I'm talk is being robbed yeah I don't I
don't go near Dino DNA that uh show
stinks
so my question is the title a monster
hunter world like is there any
significance to framing it that way
rather than giving it a solid number uh
yeah I think at the end of the trailer
it kind of pulls out and kind of moves
through this entire massive you yeah I
don't know if this if it's like we've
got this massive complete wall now
instead of a region it's prettier or I
could be like a multiplayer and alluding
to like a persistence to the multiplayer
that's kind of what I'm hoping yeah I
think that'd be real cool yeah how you
make that work is I don't know it could
be like crew factions and and that kind
of stuff but it looks real cool and it
looks like they put a lot of the
learnings from the recent monster hunter
games into it and looks like it's selfie
but active when you've got a lot of the
weapons and styles that you're used to
seeing in modern 100 games in there
representing I think for a lot of fans
of the series this is a big get and I
think it will do a pretty good in kind
of moving PlayStation units in certain
territories like you know Monster Hunter
is a pretty big deal in Japan this could
be this could be something that kind of
gives Sony a boost in Japan and sells a
few more extra fierce Wars hmm and then
after we saw at Marvel vs. Capcom yes
boy that was um the humor in that
trailer was like Kim is like you've seen
that picture of like data from Star Trek
or it goes computer please let tell me
about humor very robotic there's
something about I think I don't know why
but Marvel vs. Capcom 3 looks better
than this game what's up a Chinese face
Tommy's face is too scary it looks like
so it looks like someone wearing a
chun-li mask yeah yeah quite frightening
her yeah yeah um but I think there's
something about the way this game looks
that it's lacking some detail which
is really upsetting but then there was a
period when Marvel vs. Capcom free
looked a bit rough for a long time and
then they had this final pass on it just
before it came out and looked incredible
and I think like they really Linney
leaning into the cinematic nature of
this game with the story stuff and
although I feel like it's good to do
that Capcom R it's in the interest to do
that considering the flag they get from
having a very thin story experience in
Street Fighter 5 and they're in in a
world where injustice is absolutely
incredible in the story and Mortal
Kombat is great and even technically
sister oh god please
alright what's an eyebrow um but like I
feel like I don't know as someone who's
seen Capcom's storytelling chops in
Street Fighter and that kind of stuff
I'm not that excited
I wish they'd come and said hey we have
this person from Marvel writing the
story from us for us but they haven't
done that but it's cool you know I kept
a geek out about all these comic-book
characters and Capcom characters coming
to pose in a you know series that I love
I'm up for that it's got black panther
in it which awesome I'll be hearing
about the control scheme I I played it
recently and it's definitely simplified
they've simplified the mechanics of it
but it still got quite a lot of depth I
was surprised at how much depth they
kind of still it still has it has it's
opened the mechanics up for creativity
in a way that is going to be I think
appreciated by the marble community
quite a bit because by the end of you
know current Marvel you know certain
combos of characters and you know
certain strategies and loops and that
kind of stuff and I feel like with the
introduction of the Infinity stones it
gives a little people a little more
variety you know how they can approach
different characters and you can do
things like equip a gem that makes Hulk
super fast which is crazy but didn't
that also like kind of backfire first
Street Fighter cross Tekken it did but I
feel like it fits better here with
Marvel and because that the Infinity
stones are really using in an
interesting way they're using them to
kind of mess with the fundamental design
principles of a fighting game so like
using it to control space or speed or
remove startup and and cooldown frames
or like rebalancing that kind of stuff
okay so they're kind of experimenting
with the underlying mechanics of things
so second a is inverses of you yeah
exact
it's really really interesting and I'm
like I'm not 100% sold on it but I can
see the vision and from what I played of
it it seems to be coming together really
well
so yeah I'm excited about that game Tori
demo available
sorry demo available now although right
now and I've got work to do as I'm well
bummed I know I know it's okay it'll
still be there when you get back yeah uh
what else do we get we had ecology
trailer that was Paulo's duty as can be
I mean I am very surprised at the
showing of both call of duty and destiny
too because I was like you know they
have this exclusive content partnership
relationship going on with Playstation
you'd think that they would do yeah it's
just again they were very plain trailers
they were very cool of G trailer yeah
well and very destinated didn't speak
out yeah thing and it's like I think I
feel like they're just these two
trailers more than any of them they're
like ticking boxes like yeah you give
you give the shoe you shoot your friends
actually in bit and yeah I don't and if
you have to pick two franchise
franchises that you don't really need to
sell it seems to all of you yeah maybe I
I have to feel for them what do you show
especially because it's pretty well worn
territory especially in like Normandy
they said they said you go to Crimea
later on I didn't know you're going that
far and look this looks good though like
yeah it looks like good like it and I'm
interested in playing it I'm sure it's
gonna be a good game for as a trailer in
a press conference it's kind of boring
like buried into the background yeah you
quickly it's very much a Call of Duty
trailer and that's you that's quite
damning yeah I didn't show anything that
really piqued my interest past what it
already was yeah cuz I'm gonna play it
regardless but now I'm still kind of me
I love like how how how much is going on
in this and it makes me it does make me
remind me of that first time I played
Medal of Honor or the first ecology and
yes I'm excited for it
but like I said it's just kind of a land
trailer yeah and then you know you go
over to destiny and it was kind of I
guess someone who liked played a lot of
the first destiny what they showed of
destiny to tonight it was kind of not
what I wanted to see I don't think you
very much just yeah I was like a little
small shooter level like more of a
linear space but then they're shelling
shedding more light on the
character for his name coming to school
yes uh I don't know looks like a vein
like a what like pain they said a vein
yeah the vein in my forehead though yeah
popping he I'm excited for this game to
play it I'm to see what they actually
learned throughout the time obviously
the fact that taken King ever existed
and changed up what was what I thought
was wrong with the base game excites me
for what they could do with a full
sequel yeah um but yeah this trailer
didn't really excite me either
I don't yeah I try to be negative on
everything but these two in particular
yeah I mean I said you don't need to
really sell those two franchises like I
don't want to be negative about this
press conference but given the high bar
that Sony consistently set and given the
competition that they knew they would be
up against this year and with the Xbox
one X they kind of didn't yeah and I
feel like it's worth stressing that like
despite what we're saying that we're
excited about those two games like I
personally I'm excited for destiny and
ecology but it's just they didn't show
well here they weren't exciting they
were dry we're not gonna walk out of
this talking about it later to know
exactly it was like it existed and it
still exists cool alright let's let's
talk about some VR so can we stop
bringing Skyrim to e3 how can we stop by
god big house make the next Elder
Scrolls game hi I'm sick of it it's a
good game it was good it's still just
leave it now it's a moneymaker man yeah
uh I'm gonna buy that
yeah I'm gonna buy VR headset for that
no I'm gonna buy that you just trying to
sound positive now yeah I know that if I
had a psvr that would be I would play
that HP yeah see bucks for it
ye Wow I would be interested sure if
it'll switch to though yeah I forgot
about that uh switches also graceful
interface you'll be fine
scarf it gr yeah I really V are you
ready just lie down on your pillow put
the VR headset on and play Skyrim is
being released on two different
platforms
two different platforms or in
oh I don't know how many in time I do
wonder how it's gonna mix with like
obviously had special-edition come last
year sure and is it ok buy it again for
the VR is they I don't think Skyrim's a
psvr exclusive is it because fall off
and see the fall off or is coming to all
three pair OFS it won't today they'll
put it everywhere eventually there might
be like a time delay thing but um I
almost would have been more excited for
that if they show to epithets de right
after fallout like the one th but I
guess yeah I guess I I think Nintendo
would have been like yo yeah sure um in
terms of other via titles we had star
child mm-hmm don't even remember it
barely it looked like uh it looked like
a platformer that I don't want to play
that much yet from less yeah yeah I can
likely boring platformer a showed him
jumping a couple times
okay I'm take to make the comparison but
like look at the games that the indie
games the idea Xbox games that Microsoft
showed each one of them had something
unique and memorable about them this
could looks kind of generic ones
anything by generic me it doesn't you
exactly it doesn't look all that
interesting which is odd because like a
couple years ago it was Sony that e3
that was usually like a coma was
announced on the Sony stage right they
had when the ps4 first launched it was
really pushing for Indies I mean to
launch me I don't know it now it seems
like this show it was reversed yeah it
didn't seem know that they had much from
the XF program yeah but then they did
have her from supermassive they had the
impatient that looks interesting like
supermassive blew us all away
caught us by surprise with until dawn so
out of all of them all the games that
they show that's the one that I'm most
kind of optimistic and interested in
seeing its a VR game so like that gives
me a reason to kind of pull out my
PlayStation VR and check it out but um
it does sort of have the vibe of like a
kind of run off of until dawn right
those kind of like like I'm talking
specifically about those bits in the
middle whether it's you in the sidecar
yeah
yeah I know this isn't also like again
there's a lot of these types of games in
VR right now yeah
is that will wilson's however is called
and that kind of like very similar vibe
to it and like I'm not sure what's
what's different about it I mean it
looked really nice and they showed that
day it wasn't the stuffing until dawn
that was really cool wasn't the the
atmosphere or that kind of stuff it was
the decision-making stuff and how the
story branched and they didn't show any
of that so like at the moment I'm
interested in it but if they don't show
some some of that stuff I probably I
might back away a bit the fact that VR
game makes me think they're not gonna
like lean into the decision-making as
much I mean for VR but I think VR I
don't think those things I think
atmosphere and tone maybe that yeah game
looks like it's going for those more huh
but who knows uh then we got probably
the biggest surprise of the show Final
Fantasy 15 fishing okay come on the hell
not oh yeah
I thought seems interesting cuz I didn't
play prompt dough's uh I didn't realize
that was out that's why I didn't talk
about a 15 I was a game okay game yeah
that's a good game yeah um something out
of tag get it I mean there is I'd rather
just you can fish in ocarina of time
yeah um so I think it's fair to say that
no one saw this coming
no but it's cool like it's fun people
are vying for hold on a second cool
being people of those character wants
people love those characters I think
they are yeah been anime archetypes
listen don't be milk about money other
than you don't think it's cool I I think
it's cool that Square Enix's understands
that people love these characters for
some reason I don't think they like
giving us a fishing game with these
carrots I think it had little more than
that you had them like sitting around
the LM fighting talking and Nathan Drake
is interesting to me I was fishing as
him yeah but like would you go fishing
with him now well there what if they
made like I know I'm not a I'm not a
weed what would you go fishing with
Nathan Drake so that's that's the point
my like you go fishing with the guy then
cook meal with the guys it kind of fits
in thematically right it's all about a
road trip with your lads and you kind of
hanging out you're fishing you make
food and people like those characters
for some reason or another they like the
idea of camping with them so letting you
put on a VR headset fish with them sit
around while Ignace talks about coming
up with a new recipe or you know Prompto
tries to take a photo of your face and
show you how cool his camera is some
people like that
I'm not saying small or cool it was cool
Wow and it was cool that Square Enix
understands that those I don't think the
ingredients are out there another giving
them what they want but okay you could
say the same thing about like the people
who like shooting games like they're
deviants out there that just want to see
shooting and Call of Duty they showed
them that wasn't good if that call of do
you guys put his gun down and slide
fishing all right fine
uh we had Bravo team that also super
massive know that the logo just
lingering I think the last I'll go a
super massive logo came up right before
it I guess where I've seen that about a
hundred times on the App Store like that
looks like it looks like tomorrow point
generic toyoda
yeah ever it looks like I I mean I don't
know shooters and now I just arising
like robot wreak robo recall robot
recall yeah uh far point I mean like how
does like I don't mean to be rude but
how does this get on a press conference
stage like what about it did Sony see
and go yes this is what we need on our
stage that slide though it's just I
don't send it it's like this is slim
pickings for VR that's what it feels
like we scraped the bottom of the barrel
for VR and this is what we got for you
and they weren't even announcing it like
alongside the controller that they
released for farm yeah right yeah right
it's just I don't understand it my way
and then we had Stuart Little the game
Moss um he was gonna look cute yeah look
nice yeah a silky Mouse in big big ears
I just wanna see yeah it was good I
think it's trying to be like a bit of an
oriental blown for a style thing for
them and I don't know is it I can't do a
little in the room and yeah Stuart and
the rather large first and it looks cool
like I still knowing who's cool as in
the muff looks cool look him look him
right now he's cute why not like an
infinity phone that made a game that's
on his arm that's cool doh Oh
eat all right I feel like we're
stretching for compliments for what
we've been talking about I think it was
cool
uh-huh all right Detroit looks cool it
feels very different than what it was
less coated oh I think I think now that
it's further on in development they have
just gone full David yeah yeah yeah it's
just like all right he's making it now
let's just went from like it wasn't the
first showing like this crime scene that
the detective was hurting and now it's
nothing like that Android there's no
connection
character so basically I think that was
just I don't know if you're gonna play
from the human side as well but that
just seemed like the Android had gone
crazy and was gonna kill the kid I
thought this was like world building
like you none of these characters are
the main character even though that guy
at the end is like this is our story or
whatever that kind of positions him I
feel like you play a detective in this
world trying to figure out what's going
on or something and this is kind of like
setting up the fiction and the kind of
the state of the world and it's like
it's well-trodden territory at this
point the stuff that they doing I was
watching and it looks pretty and I like
the futuristic vibe that it's going for
but the actual themes and the subject
matter oh it's a bit Bicentennial much
yes it also reminds me of what mankind
divided did they weren't full androids
they're August ovens it seems like the
same thing kind of like freedom for them
and whatnot um didn't look like there's
much gameplay at all I got the gated
show is you picking between three
different things take cover runner yeah
do something else like this this is just
like you pausing a cutscene just to
overlay some text and I don't understand
yeah but that infographic though yeah
that hot hot infographic that comes up
in a second yeah and these are
apparently famous people she was in
almost-human which I never thought I'd
get the chance to name-drop that show
twice in two days but he seems was aged
out of the woods a little smart one yeah
yeah but you thought he was yeah um he
the one from Grey's Anatomy everyone
who's talking about tweeting about
Grey's Anatomy I'm not a steamy
dreamy McDreamy why are we talking about
Grey's Anatomy on a video game there is
that game um but yeah again looks
drawing okay
retching for confluence yeah okay well I
think one game at least we can
definitely be complimentary about was
this vitamin the insomniac spider-man no
I don't know man Creed oh god it was not
fun and the game looks fun I agree I
think it looks i think they spent i
think it looks cool I'm excited about it
I love that it's more Miles Morales I
think I think it sort of predict they
avoided the swinging quite a lot it was
a lot of not swinging happening
yeah the I thought when he was fighting
uh those guys and it looked real slick
and he could it was bet it was Arkham
Knight combat that's what I was I
personally hate that stuff I can't I
don't know it's no fun contextual combat
is not my bag I mean that there was a
lot of cuties yeah a lot of QT maker
they stripped those I thought this
looked really fun um unlike other no the
navigation seems smooth to me definitely
hitching a little bit here and there but
yeah up I feels like I was getting the
job done there was a spite of my game a
couple years ago that were that was made
and I think it's the amazing spider-man
games I think those games they're they
care a rough rep but I think this
swinging they have in those is really
cool the cinematic way they do it the
way kind of like he goes really close to
the ground and the camera swoops in
underneath him and like I remember
playing those and getting a genuine
sense of exhilaration swinging around
the city it did kind of like that this
doesn't have that right and and the fact
that they they should have opened with
swinging like swing into a fight don't
like the swings in between him kind of
like chasing something and it's kind of
distracting you from it and it's not
clear how it works it also didn't feel
it didn't look like you had much choice
on why you were gonna go incredibly
ripped it obviously it's gonna be
scripted yeah um oh my god I don't know
if I don't think for me personally
wasn't a game that looked a little bit
too linear it was the demo and they were
trying to show I don't think that's what
they should have shown for this game but
yeah I think the thing we want from a
spider-man game is an open-world
environment where you can just swing
around and save save people and do
missions and that kind of stuff and this
just doesn't seem like that it seems
very very focused on going where exactly
where the developer wants and obviously
that is partly because they have a you
know a presentation to do in this
scenario but I feel like you missed
really missed a trick by not just
opening
things up a bit and showing everyone you
know an opportunity the opportunity that
you have to swing around the city and do
interesting things and have fun of your
own making instead of doing exactly what
they want you to yeah uh in general I
like this demo I started okay I think
it's got potential I think I think the
scripting is quite good as well because
I'm I think I mentioned this I say I
hate it when characters talk to
themselves I absolutely despise it um
but I think that in keeping with
spider-man's like lighter tone and it
was quite quickly and it was you know
very Marvel movie esque yeah um which I
enjoyed um like I said Miles Morales
yeah cool my boy thank all right um
overall thoughts that actually I just
checked my email and turns out that
monster hunter is not ps4 exclusive it's
Xbox one and PC great which is awesome
but like given I in mind given that all
that kind of the big supplies if that
does yeah cross make it less impressive
I guess cuz yeah yeah I mean that does
kind of take one of the pheasant feather
the elevator of their cap and I kind of
alright
oh that's Sony's conference kind of like
six out of ten you were very slick at
changing that sign you like I don't even
know what he's doing it also no more
Skyrim please not done with this year
but six out of ten alright let's try and
end on animal positive note what was
your highlight of the conference Shadow
the Colossus yes playing simple very
easy yeah my - all right wait spider-man
just cuz he said chattel classes I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go shout out the
closes as well who's about you yeah
alright what have you get six out of ten
yeah that's exciting I reckon six out of
ten it was kind of hard
Ubisoft conference to follow up today
yeah conference I know this isn't the
Ubisoft post show but I enjoyed that
count on these close conference as good
as pray huh oh look oh my god the
primetime Russell right there yeah I
need to separate give this guy but
anyway thank you for joining us for
Sony's post show breakdown I guess you'd
call it
we are here all week at e3 eat what have
you written still no more scaring almost
guys I just really want to drive this
home I know it's okay maybe they'll stop
now maybe they'll see your sign and
maybe they'll stop tweet this to Todd
house and Pete Hines out behind but
thank you for joining us we are here all
week for the rest of e3 so whether you
join us YouTube twitch facebook or
gamespot.com we are here with all the
latest news from e3 2017 so make sure
you stick around